he's going to talk about how robust okay
so I'd like to thank the organizers for
inviting me the talk is how our bus tour
linear sketches to adaptive inputs this
is joint work with more its heart okay
so this talk is going to cover two
aspects of coping with big data the
first is a standard efficiency aspect
you want to design algorithms to handle
enormous inputs so you want the usual
guarantees of very low memory very fast
processing time etc but we're also going
to look at a robustness condition
meaning that the algorithm can handle
adverse conditions and more specifically
for this talk what we're going to have
is the inputs may be chosen to try to
break the algorithm so we have some
randomized algorithm which may use it's
the same randomness to answer different
queries and the query might try to break
the correctness of this algorithm and
the big goal is can we achieve both
efficient and robust algorithms so the
algorithmic paradigm we're going to look
at in the talk is that of a linear
sketch linear sketches have many
applications compressed sensing data
streams distributed computation
numerical linear algebra etc and the
basic idea behind these is that you have
your data and you want to perform a
small number of linear measurements on
this data now what does that mean more
formally you have some large data vector
X in R to the N and you try to squish it
down by applying a linear map a chosen
from some distribution which is usually
independent of the data vector you
compute your sketch y equals ax which is
in our dimensions and typically r is
much smaller than the original
n-dimensional space and then you output
some function
some arbitrary function of this sketch
vector Y okay and what is correctness
mean so typically people prove a so
called for each correctness and it's the
following so for each input data vector
X the probability over a randomly chosen
sketchy matrix a that the algorithm
succeeds is at least one minus one over
poly n so high probability okay a
natural question is does this imply
correctness on many inputs can the
sketch be used to answer many queries
and this is true only under a modeling
assumption for instance if the inputs
are non adaptively chosen then by a
simple Union bound we can just say that
the algorithm is correct on a polynomial
number of them however what happens if
say the input X 2 depends on the output
of the algorithm for an earlier input x1
now we can't apply this Union bound in
fact there's no guarantee in this case
that the algorithm will still be correct
and I think a good example to see why
the algorithm a classical sketch will
fail is is to look at the Johnson
lindenstraße sketch so what is that so
here the goal is to estimate estimate
the Euclidean norm of your input vector
X or equivalently the squared euclidean
norm from the squared euclidean norm of
the sketch ax so one way of doing this
and there are many ways of doing it is
to use a so-called johnson lindenstraße
sketch which goes back to the Johnson
lindenstraße dilemma and one formulation
of this says that if a is a k by n
matrix of iid normal random variables
with mean 0 and variance 1 over k then
provided the number of rows of this
matrix a which is k
is just a little bit just a little bit
larger than log n then you already have
this very strong for each correctness
guarantee namely the probability over
this choice of matrix a that the
Euclidean norm of ax is within a
constant factor of the Euclidean norm of
X is at least one minus one over poly n
okay so it succeeds on poly n on
adaptively chosen inputs however there's
a very simple attack to this sketch
which only makes one adaptive query and
it's the following so the algorithm what
it does is it queries the input vector x
equals e I for the i th standard I basis
vector and it also queries x equals e i
+ ej for the sum of two standard basis
basis vectors and it does this for all I
and J now what is the attacker learn
from the output of the sketch well by
definition of the sketch when I apply it
to e I I learned the squared euclidean
norm of the I column of a and when I
apply to EJ I learned the squared
euclidean norm of that Jeff column of a
and when I apply it to AI + ej I learned
the squared euclidean norm of AI plus aj
but now i can just solve an equation
with these three quantities to learn the
inner product of the i'th column and the
jet column of the sketching matrix ok so
now consider the matrix a transpose a
what did the entries of this matrix look
like well they all have the form inner
product AI AJ for two columns of a all
of the entries so I know the entire
matrix a transpose a and in particular
this matrix has the same kernel as the
matrix a so I learned the colonel of the
sketching matrix a
if I know the colonel the sketching
matrix then what I can do is just the
following I query a vector X which is in
the kernel of the sketching matrix on
the one hand this is a nonzero vector so
it has nonzero norm on the other hand
the output of the sketch will be zero
since it's in the colonel so it can
achieve a relative error so it's just
one adaptive query here already shows
that Johnson lindenstraße sketches do
not tolerate adaptively chosen inputs
okay and I want to stress that
correlations they arise in nearly any
realistic setting so there's sort of the
natural or harmless model where say
you're using a network traffic monitor
using a sketch and you're deciding where
to send traffic based on the output of
the sketch and that that traffic might
you know become a future input at some
point and so the question here of
robustness is can we prove correctness
on this distribution but there's also a
much more adversarial example where
there is sort of a denial of service
attack on the network and now someone is
sort of actively trying to rear out
packets by looking at the output of the
sketch and trying to fool it and here
the robustness question is can we sort
the attack so in this talk what we're
going to show is strong and possibility
results for algorithms for which you can
adaptively choose inputs and to formally
state the theorem let me introduce a a
problem that we come up with which is
the gap norm problem parametrized by
some parameter b and it's a promise
problem and it states the following
given a vector X in R to the end you
want to decide if you're in a yes case
meaning the squared to norm of X is at
least this parameter B or you're in a no
case meaning the square to norm is at
most one
and if you're not in either case the
output can be either yes or no and we're
going to show impossibility for this
very basic problem and I should note
that this problem is actually very
easily solvable in this for each model
of correctness that I mentioned earlier
basically you can solve it for B equals
1 plus epsilon using a sketch with login
over epsilon squared rows using the
daunting lindenstraße lemma so this
provides a strong separation and the
main result is as follows for every
parameter B if you're given Oracle
access to the linear sketch and the
linear sketch only uses slightly
non-trivial dimension so it's number of
rows is n minus the log factor then I
mean it's at most n minus the log factor
then we can find in time polynomial in
the number of rows and this parameter be
a distribution on inputs for which the
sketch fails with high probability to
solve the gap norm problem the attack is
efficient it's polynomial in the number
of rows so this in particular rules out
cryptographic solutions which might
place a time bounds on the attacker and
it applies even to slightly non-trivial
sketching dimension right so if I have n
dimensions I of course can't break the
sketch because it can store the input
vector exactly since Euclidean norm is
related up to a polynomial factor to an
ELP norm we get the same result for any
LP norm and moreover the same result
holds even if the the function being
applied to the sketch vector ax is a
randomized function I mean the sketches
is fixed but the function can use
randomness ok one other application of
our result is to compress sensing so
this is the l2 l2 sparse recovery
problem
the problem is as follows given an input
vector X you would like to output a
vector X prime for which the distance
between X and X prime is that most c
times the euclidean norm of X sub tale
of K what does that mean it means I take
my vector X I take it stop k
coefficients in magnitude and I'm
replace them with zeros so in particular
if if X is only has k nonzero entries
then X will equal X Prime and in general
the closer X is to a case bars vector
the better the error is and applying our
theorem forget norm we can show for this
problem there's no linear sketch with
fewer than n over C squared rows which
can guarantee the l2 l2 sparse recovery
problem with approximation factor C on a
polynomial number of adaptively chosen
inputs and I should mention that this is
actually a tight at least for for small
values of K you can actually achieve n
over C squared using deterministic
sketching matrices I also want to note
that this is a in the for each model of
correctness you can do much better you
can achieve a number of rows which is
only K log n over K to get the same
guarantee there are some positive
results for this problem and work with
Emma Hemingway Strauss and and looters
you can get some upper bounds but they
rely on assumptions that can't be
realized by a linear sketch in
particular one assumption is that the
norm of the input vector X is known
exactly which is what we're going to
show is not not possible okay so
the outline of the talk I'm going to go
over a sketch of a proof of this theorem
for gap norm and it's proved using a
linear algebraic reconstruction attack
which I'll go into I won't have time to
discuss the sparse recovery result but
it follows by reduction from this gap
norm problem and if you're interested in
I encourage you to look at the paper
okay so to it to give a proof of this
theorem let's first formally define this
computational model of a linear sketch
so an hour dimensional linear sketch can
be viewed as follows it can be viewed as
any function f from RN to in this case
201 so a 0 would be if I'm in a no
instance for gap norm and the one if I'm
in a yes instance and the function
satisfies the following that for every X
in RN f of X is equal to f of the
projection of X onto a subspace you
which is our dimensions so we can
identify this sketch with with some
dimensional subspace you now why does
this capture a general linear sketch
well as i said earlier a general linear
sketch has the form a times X and so
what I mean ax + u transpose X are
equivalent if u transpose if the rows of
u transpose span the same space as the
rows of a because I can always let x a
change of row basis so for any u
transpose with the same row space these
two sketches or equivalent I can go from
one to the other so in particular I can
choose u transpose to have orthonormal
rose and at that point the sketch u
transpose X is equivalent to this to the
sketch of the projection of X onto you
because that has the form uu transpose X
and I can go from one to the other by
left multiplying by you or u transpose
ok
so this is just a convenient way of
viewing a linear sketch as identifying
it with some subspace you that's our
dimensional and since we're going to be
proving impossibility results we're
going to allow this function f to have
unbounded computational power on top of
so what it sees is the projection of X
onto you and it can do whatever it wants
I mean we're going to be proving an
impossibility results or our result is
only stronger but probably for real
applications you'd want f to be
efficient ok so the reconstruction
attack is as follows so as input you're
given Oracle access to this sketching
function f using some unknown subspace
you of our dimensions and your goal is
to try to reconstruct the subspace you
ok so we initialize V sub 0 to be the 0
vector a subspace of zero dimension and
this is what we start off knowing about
this unknown subspace you and we're
going to update this throughout the
course of the algorithm so for t equals
1 to t equals r iterations what we do is
the following we have three meta steps
the first step is the correlation
finding step and I'll go over all these
more on the next few slides but the
correlation in finding step where its
job is to do is to find vectors x1
through XM which are in some sense
weakly correlated with this unknown
subspace you and what that's going to
turn out to mean is that the projection
onto the subspace you is a little bit
larger in magnitude then uh then a
random vectors projection onto you would
be we're going to try to find these
vectors moreover these vectors x1
through XM they're going to be
orthogonal to what we already know about
the subspace so V sub t minus 1 starts
off at v-0 we know the zero vector is
inside of it and we're slowly learning a
basis for this unknown subspace you
and we ensure that we're always
orthogonal to what we already know the
next step is a boosting step so we have
all these vectors x1 through XM which
are weakly correlated with this unknown
subspace and what we want is a single
vector X which is very strongly
correlated with you and you can think of
that as meaning as actually contained
inside of this subspace you and more
where it's orthogonal to what we already
know and finally there's a progress step
so what we do is we update what we know
we set V sub T to be the span of V sub t
minus 1 together with this new vector X
and after our iterations we output the
subspace V sub R and the hope is that V
sub R equals you if that's the case then
if we know the subspace we can query
something in the kernel of the subspace
and we can break the algorithm for the
same reason this Johnson Dennis Ross
sketch was broken we won't exactly learn
the subspace you will get a space V R
which is very close to the subspace you
and that will be sufficient ok so let me
go through these steps the first step is
a correlation finding step for this step
what we do is we prove a conditional
expectation lemma so the lemma is as
follows given a d-dimensional sketch f
and now i'm using this variable D
because you can think of the sketch is
changing its dimension throughout the
course of the algorithm it starts off as
an hour dimensional sketch and we're
slowly learning basis vectors in it and
reducing its dimension so just given an
arbitrary d-dimensional sketch f what we
can do is finding using Pauly D queries
we can find an input distribution G such
that the following holds the expectation
of the length of G projected onto u
squared condition on the output of the
sketch being one is slightly larger than
without this can
it's slightly larger than the expected
length of G projected onto u squared
without the conditioning by an additive
Delta so Delta is our advantage over
random and moreover this Delta is not
going to be too small it's going to be
polynomial in 1 over d the sketching
dimension and actually our query
distribution our attacking distribution
is very simple it's a Gaussian input so
it's iid Gaussian and coordinates each
one has mean 0 and the variance is Sigma
on each of these coordinates and
moreover this Sigma is going to be a the
main what we're going to do is we're
going to choose this Sigma carefully
which is unknown to the sketching
algorithm if the scheduling algorithm
new Sigma it could output sigma x n for
instance ok so just a simplification if
G is Gaussian then the projection of G
onto this space you is also Gaussian
with this covariance matrix so what we
can think of is the query distribution
as choosing a random Gaussian vector
inside this unknown subspace you this is
just for notational simplicity so in
this talk we're going to drop the
projection operator and just think of
our query distribution as choosing a
Gaussian in this unknown subspace ok so
the three-step intuition is as follows
so the queries are random Gaussian
inputs G so you have spherical symmetry
there's some unknown variance to them
but what is the sketch learn about the
query distribution which is parametrized
by this variance well everything it
learns it learns from this norm of the
input I mean of the query that vector G
because the direction doesn't matter
it's a spherically symmetric
distribution so what it learns about the
variance follows from the norm of this
this query vector G okay and the next
step is an averaging step so the idea is
that if the norm is larger than expected
intuitively the sketch is more likely to
output one why is this what we know by
correctness if the norm is very large if
you're solving the gap known problem you
should be outputting one if the norm is
very small you should be outputting zero
so the intuition is that if its larger
than expected you should output one it's
not quite true but via an averaging
argument will show it's true in a
certain sense and finally again
intuitively by a sort of Bayes rule I
can reverse this conditioning so instead
if I condition on the output of the
sketch being one then the expectation of
this norm is likely to be larger and
that's the goal for the conditional
expectation lemma condition on the
output being one the expectation is
likely to be larger ok so let me go
through this more formally so define
this function P of s to be the
probability that the sketch outputs one
on input vector Y where we conditioned
on the squared euclidean norm of y 2
equal s then we have the following a
simple property for an input Gaussian
vector G if it has expected squared norm
T then we can just compute the
probability that the sketch outputs one
on this input G what is it what's the
integral over all possible input norms a
zero to infinity s of new sub T of s now
this is the density of the chi-squared
distribution so the expectation is t
because it's just the sum of the squared
normal random variables and we've chosen
its expectation BTW so what we do is
this is the density function the
probability that the input has squared
ms and then it's a random spherically
symmetric input so then p of s if i
multiplied by P of s which is the
probability the sketch upwards one given
vector of that norm then I exactly get
the probability to sketch outputs one
okay so it's useful to consider the
following plot on the y-axis we're going
to plot this function P of s that I just
defined on the x-axis we're going to
plot this squared norm F okay so P of S
is a probability it's between 0 and 1
the norm s can be from 0 to infinity but
we're sort of most interested in looking
at the range 1 to be this is the gap
norm range and what do we know by
correctness well as I said by
correctness when the norm is very small
the PFS should be 0 because you know it
should solve the problem for most
vectors of small norm when the norm is
very large PFS should be 1 this is just
correctness now the main question is
what goes on in between these two
extremes so who knows I mean in a very
nice world we get this linear
interpolation between these two extremes
that would be a very nice sketch but
there's no reason the sketch needs to
behave this way right the sketch can get
its own very accurate estimation to the
input norm and if it notices it's not
near 1 and B it can do whatever at once
inside of this range for instance once
the norm is slightly larger than 1 it
might all of a sudden always output 1 or
it might not even be monotonic I mean it
might it might look like this but we
really can't rule out what the sketch is
doing in between 1 and B okay but what
we can do using a probabilistic method
type argument is show that there exists
some tea so that if I query a Gaussian
distribution with the expected squared
to norm T
then I do have this following property
now this property is not enough for the
conditional expectation lemma but what
it says is the following it says that if
i look at all norms to the right of this
T but look at the probability that the
sketch outputs one integrated to the
right of T so this is the integral over
s of the chi square distribution with
mean t evaluated at s times P of s 40
going from t to infinity if I also look
at this probability on the left of this
expectation T then these two
probabilities differ by an additive
Delta so that's kind of close to a
conditional expectation lemma I mean it
means if I choose this this this
expectation T then I'm slightly I mean
the probably that I output one if I'm on
the right is slightly larger than the
property I output one if I'm on the left
that doesn't really give you the
conditional expectation lemma though
because you could have a pathological
case we're sort of all the mass even
though this probability is larger all of
the the norms are very close on the
right to the expectation but on the left
there very far from the expectation and
so what we really would like to show is
that this given that the sketch outputs
one this expected projection length is
larger than T plus Delta and this
doesn't immediately follow from this
probabilistic statement so we need to do
a little bit more work and what I what
we're going to do is what I want to call
sliding look at sliding chi-squared
distributions yeah
no so Sigma very small like less than 1
or so but I mean you might oh yeah so
there has to be some reasonable
probability that this sketch actually
outputs one this is another condition
that we can show for this choice of tea
so I gloss that under the rug that
actually you want to find the tea not
only sort of this conditional
expectation lemma holds but also that
the probability that the sketch outputs
one given that value of T is at least
one of our poly d because we're actually
going to need a sample from this
distribution okay you caught me so I
tried to hide that okay so to prove this
conditional expectation lemma we're
going to look at sliding chi-square
distributions so what does this mean so
for each possible input squared input
norm s we're going to define a quantity
Delta of s and what it's going to do is
it's going to integrate over all
possible chi-squared distributions with
mean between 1 and T and the chi-square
distribution the mean is going to be
sorry between 1 and B and what we do is
we have this input norm s and and one of
these sums in the integrand one of these
terms of the integrand will correspond
to some chi square distribution VT of s
and what we do is we multiply the weight
of s under that chi square distribution
with the the signed distance from s to
the mean so s minus T times the density
of s under the sky square distribution
with mean T ok so I think probably this
is best explained with a picture so what
we have is a bunch of chi-squared
distributions here parameterize by
different means t equals 1 2 etc the
yellow is a chi-squared distribution
with mean one then i get a chi-squared
distribution with mean to this green and
so what you can see is that the
chi-square distribution not only is the
the mean girl
but the variance is also growing as
theta T it's it's fattening out and why
don't we just look at Delta of 4 s
equals 4 and why don't we look at the
contribution from the chi squared
distribution with mean to and the chi
squared distribution with mean six so
when i plug in s equals four and T
equals 2 i'll get a 4-2 a 2 scaled by
the density of four under the
chi-squared distribution with mean to
and sort of symmetrically what I'll get
is a when i plug in s equals 4 and T
equals 6 i'll get a minus 2 scale by the
density of a four-under the distribution
with mean six so the two and the minus
two you know you might hope things
cancel 20 this is where the point for
lies on the density function for T
equals two okay now this is where the
point for lies on the density function
for T equals six it's larger and this is
basically because the variances is
spreading out so what that means is this
2 gets multiplied by something smaller
than the minus 2 got x and so basically
what this means is that Delta s is
almost always negative except when s
gets very large s gets close to this
boundary be or much larger than be s can
go to infinity but Delta s is mostly
negative now another interesting
property here though is actually if you
integrate Delta F over all possible
values of s you actually get zero the
reason is so I just plug in this
expression for Delta of s in the
integral is given here and if I
integrate with respect to s first then
what I'll get is
s times the density of a chi-squared
distribution that's just the expectation
if i integrate over all s so i get t t
minus t this becomes 0 and so this
integral of delta s overall s is
actually 0 even though delta s is uh is
negative for most values of s that are
small and positive for for large values
of s so they cancel and you get zero and
via some calculations if we were in a
very nice world and this 0 / 1 / Pauly D
instead we'd be done you have to believe
me on that but so how can we so one
thing we haven't used so far is
correctness of the algorithm so recall
that P of S is the probability that f of
y equals 1 given a uniformly random
input vector with squared to norm s and
the correctness condition is for small s
P of S is about 0 and four large s P of
S is about one okay so now let's look at
that interval again it evaluated at 0
but let's also put a p of s inside of
the integral P of s times Delta of s now
what's going to happen when s is really
small we said Delta of s is negative and
P of S is 0 by correctness when s is
very small so P of s times Delta VES I'm
zeroing out some negative contribution
to the integral on the other hand when s
is very large the Delta of s is positive
and P of S is also one in that case I'm
reinforcing some positive contribution
to this integral so actually this
integral is no longer 0 if I put it in a
p of s there it's a little bit larger
it's D and via some calculations you can
just show that this implies that the
conditional expectation lemma namely by
averaging the regs
this a choice of mean T so that the
expected value condition on the sketch
outputting one is a little bit larger
than T so that's the conditional
expectation lemma the next step is a
boosting lemma so we want to find a
single vector X which is very strongly
correlated with this unknown subspace
you and the idea is as follows so we
found this input distribution for which
we can sample Pauly D vectors and get
this slight bias when the sketch outputs
one my length the length of my
projection onto you is a little bit
larger than expected so what I do is I
take all those input vectors for which
the sketch out put it one on that
distribution and I arrange them into a
matrix so I take Polly d samples I have
a matrix with polity rows and n columns
and now it turns out that the top right
singular vector of this matrix is
extremely correlated with this unknown
subspace you so what I got is all these
x1 through XM s which are a little bit
correlated with this unknown subspace
you and I sort of aggregated their
correlations by computing this top right
singular vector which is very close to
being contained in the subspace you
namely we can show that the length of
its projection onto the subspace is at
least 1 minus Polly 1 over d I mean the
intuition here is that the four four
vectors which have a large component in
the orthogonal space to you they're
their unbiased by the the sketch
outputting one because the sketch has no
information about vectors that are
orthogonal to to its subspace so
basically there exists a good a good
vector in the subspaces which is
correlated with all these vectors that
follows by the conditional expectation
llama and any vector which is far from
the subspace would not be correlated
with as many of these vectors
as largely as that vector basically
because the sketch doesn't doesn't have
any information about the orthogonal
complement okay so yeah so the proof is
just we do a net argument and we use the
Chernoff bound this is where we needed
the expectation in the conditional
expectation lemma it wasn't enough just
to get a bias in probabilities okay so
there are a few details left to the
algorithm the algorithm can actually be
implemented in poly our time where r is
the number of rows of the sketching
matrix as I described it it would
actually be Polly end time but there's
no reason to use all n dimensions if you
can write the sketch by using only the
first hour plus a logarithmic number of
dimensions so basically you can take
your R by n matrix and just restrict it
to the first r plus o log n be columns
and put zeros on the remaining
coordinates of your queries and so this
effectively makes this matrix m and R by
order our matrix and now the singular
value decomposition is efficient in
terms of the number of rows of the
sketch and so basically the reason the
iteration works the reason the overall
algorithm works is the following so in
an intermediate step in the algorithm
what you're doing is you're querying a
Gaussian vector orthogonal to what
you've already learned about the unknown
subspace and intuitively each step in
the iteration reduces the sketching
dimension by one and after our
iterations the sketch has no dimensions
left on the other hand your query space
still has at least n minus R dimensions
and so this is effectively why you can
query something in the kernel of this
the sketch and and give a distribution
for which the sketch fails there is one
problem which is actually you don't
actually learn the unknown subspace you
exactly exactly this is because it's
very hard to find a vector which is
exactly contained in the unknown
space you just get something close to it
so as you iterate the sketch technically
still has our dimensions you can fix
this by adding a small amount of
Gaussian noise to all the end
coordinates and then the sketch can't
tell if you're querying a low
dimensional subspace plus Gaussian noise
versus something very close to a low
dimensional subspace plus Gaussian noise
so that's the algorithm and we've we've
gone through all the steps so just some
open problems we didn't optimize the
polynomial dependence it's not clear how
many polynomial adaptive queries one can
achieve with an upper bound you know
maybe for some applications if you can
achieve slightly more than a linear
number of queries this would already be
be useful in general if you need see
adaptive queries for your application
when can you do better than just
independently repeating the sketch C
times and using each of those sketches I
mean using each sketch once for each
query so I think this is an area which
is sort of overlooked in a lot of
sketching results and I think there are
lot of open questions here so that's all
thank you
oh if you have a deterministic sketch
that works for all vectors then it it
handles of course it handles adaptive
queries and that that's how you get this
upper bound for l2 l2 sparse recovery I
said this we can show an N over C
squared lower bound on the number of
rows you need for any adaptive algorithm
you can actually get a matching
algorithm by using a deterministic
sketch I think developed by Anna and
many others yeah but for the l2 problem
there is no deterministic sketch with
fewer than n rows yeah
yeah you can actually just query
something in the colonel what you end up
finding is a distribution over inputs on
which the the algorithm typically fails
so on most of the inputs the algorithm
will fail I mean you can't actually
query something directly in the colonel
you don't actually learn the colonel
exactly but it so what we prove is that
you find a distribution for which you
typically output the wrong answer yeah
linear sketch plus oh yeah linear sketch
for for certain for certain other
problems yeah if you have the length and
you have a linear sketch maybe you can
get upper bounds for some other problems
yeah that would be a good question yeah
now you're just getting all you're
getting is a bit 0 1 which so so
basically you're not getting you're
certainly not getting the sketching
matrix a and you're not getting y equals
a times X either all you're getting is
the output of the function which will
say so the function looks at the sketch
y equals a times X and it decides via
its own thoughts if it should output 0
or 1 and you see that output 0 1 and
that's all you see yeah this is a strong
I mean this this is a you get less
information this way and so it's a
stronger lower bound ok thank you